[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Would you be quiet?
I am working on a
video for YouTube.
SPEAKER 2: Our mission
is to help developers
build better apps and grow
more successful businesses
by providing tools to help
you across the lifecycle
of your app.
SPEAKER 3: You know
what's always amazing?
SPEAKER 4: Chat rooms wild card.
SPEAKER 5: This is something
people really want to know,
Michael.
SPEAKER 6: What exactly
is the life for a zombie?
SPEAKER 7: Which is
bad-- which is very bad.
[DOOR SLAMS]
SPEAKER 8: What are you doing?
SPEAKER 7: Uh, I got to go.
SPEAKER 1: Wow,
that was exciting.
SPEAKER 9: Welcome to
the Firebase Dev Summit.
SPEAKER 10: I don't know
why kids get all the fun.
Woo.